either I'm an oppressor Robinson for
gamespot on the frontline at San Diego
comic-con 2014 I am standing with some
beautiful faces who you may know what
you guys mind introducing yourself
hey I'm Jessica Nigri how's it going I'm
Angelica Hey and they are here in the
Assassin's Creed unity obstacle course I
saw you guys climbing up that wall in
your get-ups how difficult was that oh I
couldn't do it I didn't even try well
I'm in a dress so this is a different
take on the assassin so I figured it
probably shouldn't flash anybody but I'm
sure fan service would love that so I
saw that Jessica and Monika Lee both
amazing cosplayers were doing different
versions of the assassin and I'm always
trying to make like the first thing I
ever did was the female Ezio that's when
I like first did my sass in costume and
it was a skirt and I was like I need to
keep it feminine keep this going so I
wanted to do a different design so
that's why I went with a skirt instead
so obviously you know you want to give
your own magic to it but you want to
keep it as accurate as possible how do
you go about creating something that's
feminine new edgy but also accurate to
the character um I like I don't know I
kind of like to put my own spin on the
male characters because then you can
kind of do your own thing but um shoot I
don't know I just sketch it out and I
see how I feel I'm like is that gonna be
uncomfortable or for four hours probably
let's do it that way and do you sew
everything yourself how do you put it
together - I actually had some help
though with this romo awesome seamstress
maze designs and she actually helped
with these parts I made the coat then
she helped me tailor it but uh yeah like
it's a it's a combined effort for this
cuz it's impossible to do - um what
pieces did you make yourself and what
pieces did you collect everything's made
I except for like shoes and pantyhose
and stuff like that obviously but um I
do I do have help from like friends and
family like overall what would you say
is your favorite part of your entire
ensemble of course it cuz it's got these
little little knobby things right here
so just the little details and costumes
like make it amazing like for Jessica
like the little leather pieces and stuff
like that bring it all together it's
just the smallest details that make
amazing costumes i Jessica what's your
favorite piece of your in your ensemble
a phantom blade wow that is so cool
that a worbla it was like the first
thing I made and then Ubisoft retweeted
and stuff and made me feel all like
senpai notice story and stuff
made that whole thing yourself that's
incredible thank you Wow very cool
all right people find more about you
more examples of your cosplay stuff like
that I'm under angélica danger Don the
danger was accidentally put in there and
it stuck so we're going with that I'm on
Facebook and Twitter and instagrams and
stuff so find me on the interwebs and
what about you Jessica where can people
find you I just realized you're things a
dee dee it makes so much sense right
perfect
um I you can google Jessica Nigri um I
don't know if you'd want to but that's
cool if you want to ask great I've done
a couple of those asin's so is jelly
we're diehard assassin's creed she
actually has a tattoo and it's a secret
tattoo can't show hither it's right here
in this area but yes I'm pretty big fan
awesome we'll look these girls up
they've been so kind to give us an
interview and please let me know if you
put together a cosplay for San Diego
Comic Con or any other time tweet me a
picture at Anna Prosser
you